[Music]
good morning my dear
is an espionage thriller about a young
mossad agent sent to tehran for a
special mission
it's the first time that you see on
screen a completely different humane
angle of the iranian-israeli conflict
it shows the messy gray area of life
there's no black and white
and i think that's truthful
on the first season
the marabinian
infantry tehran the mission basically
failed
the second season we are two months
later tamal and milad they're stuck
hiding from the mossad and from the
zeppa faro has been chasing her for a
long time they are seemingly determined
to get out of iran but you know in this
show
plans don't work out
i can't leave yet a war against the
regime becomes really really personal
i know how to get to asa mohammadi and i
want to take him out oh
his son payman
season two deals a lot with the
hypocrisy and double standard
in tehran you have very wealthy people
connected to the regime
tamara is in a more dangerous position
which needs to get deep undercover near
the most important people in tehran and
the most dangerous people she has a lot
to lose
each person has their own story
you're not always sure exactly who's
antagonist and who's protagonist falaz
he's the most feared man in the iranian
intelligence because of his work his
wife was kidnapped and he was shocked
so naheed is dealing with ptsd
and varus is a different man now sort of
a husband
he wants to be back where he was
playing those is joining us this season
she's what he would expect from glenn
close and much more mahjong was a very
high profile psychiatrist and deep cover
massage agent
i come as a therapist for nahid
that's one of those very conflicted
moments as a psychiatrist versus an
assad agent
in our series we offer a new perspective
on tehran we really wanted to see people
in iran how do they live what do they
think
you really feel like you're deep in
another culture
it's not only about the action
there's so many layers she could trust
him can he handle it it's high stakes
but there's a lot of emotion in it the
season is much more exciting
dangerous heartbreaking it's really
intense and fast moving
and it just great entertainment
it's so much
[Music]
the fun sent me to tehran on a mission
but then everything went wrong
we have to go now
half the guard is looking for us
we can't get out
you're a good agent
we've failed this operation
but it wasn't for nothing
we're playing a long game here who sent
you
trust me
[Music]
this operation is highly classified we
need to stop him cold
are you about to work for them i have no
choice
if you pull yourself who helps you
escape
can't you handle it
i'll see it through
i know you will
it will be maximum security
dozens of separate agents
be careful
better than anyone in iran i trust you
to take care of them come on
we're going into the belly of the beast
not trained for this he can do it we
have trouble
there's been a change of plans
i'm getting us up
there is no getting out
if we screw this up i might not be able
to protect you
this plan could fail and expose our
entire network
everything depends on you
do you realize what you've done i'm
saving us
putting us all at risk
this operation is not to be compromised
you might not get out of there alive
i have to make it right
[Music]
you